Riki chomo is still waiting for news of
her two sisters and children who have
been missing since January she believes
they were members of a doomsday cult in
malindi more than 400 Canyons including
children died after their Church leader
convinced them to stve themselves in
order to meet Jesus 600 people are still
missing autopsies showed signs of
Suffocation and beatings
the shallow Graves were discovered on a
property in shakah hola in Southeastern
Kenya in our last conversation with one
of my sisters she said big things are
happening we will see each other again
but you must have faith and you must be
a believer if you don't have Jesus you
will not see
me dozens of people including the Pastor
Paul and den McKenzie are in police
custody relatives who have been waiting
for d
results thought they would have their
Answers by now but they say that
government officials are not giving them
any information and the silence is
unbearable it's believed more bodies are
buried in shakah hola the government is
struggling to identify them some are
badly
decomposed relatives are frustrated by
the long wait it's a very long process
and sometimes what we actually plead
with relatives is simply be patient
because unfortunately people think oh
with the DNA is like instant coffee I
take the DNA tomorrow you have the
results no no no no that that would be
cheating the family it may take months
sometimes years for us to be able to
identify even 10 people maen is well
known in malindi he preached against
education and medicine and has been
arrested several times over the years
relatives are demanding answers from the
government they one Justice en closure
Katherine soy Al jazer malindi Southeast
Kenya make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer